[Music]
that a girl
back in the late 90s i wrote the
ultimate guide to this nation's top
no-nonsense seats road nibbles now after
18 years i'm hitting the road again with
just an original copy of my book to
guide me
this is rose nibbles
when you find yourself in taylor texas
and you're hacking for some sizzling
pork nugs
we'll get it on up to adam's ribs and
bring your appetite
let's chime down these ribs are barack
insane oh mama i can't it's closed
next stop newport ohio where local war
hero al goshen has been serving up his
famous
cincinnati chile for over 35 years
let's get inside and chilly out
oh what god damn it you gotta be
me
this all you maurice some of michigan's
greatest local grab is served right here
no welcome oh
genius
[Applause]
there was a fixing bar right here
screw it
where's your food daddy crap
crap ah casey if you're ever in tempe
arizona
you're craving an egg salad all white
then come on down to the break room
fridge
and the live sponges travel agency don't
forget to wash it down with a tall glass
of mood juice
that's my breast milk
okay we should have researched that
better
hey thanks for watching please subscribe
to my youtube channel
so they will stop making me shoot these
videos
please
you